you how dangerous is Vladimir Putin
right now
well it's getting more dangerous
certainly I don't think we're yet at the
worst of this crisis which has got
really quite a long way to go not just
through a difficult winter but also into
a new fighting season in the spring and
summer of next year
his nuclear threats are designed to try
and frighten the West in particular and
split it off from its support for
Ukraine but we haven't yet as far as I
am aware seen any heightened Russian
state of alert for its nuclear forces
for example and there are plenty of
other steps that Putin can take to
escalate this situation short of actual
use of a nuclear weapon so
it's more of the same in a sense of
Russia trying to use use its nuclear
power status to steal territory but it
isn't yet I think a really actual threat
I suspect that although Putin is in a
difficult spot he probably does half
believe that this partial mobilization
will make a difference and it might
indeed prolong the conflict but I don't
think it will change the direction of
travel because Russia depends not just
on men and most of these new ones will
be poorly trained but also on weaponry
and ammunition and he's already been
reduced to buying uh weaponry and
ammunition from North Korea
um you mentioned a little earlier in
your answer saying that there are steps
that Putin can take to escalate the
conflict that aren't uh the use of a
nuclear weapon what kind of steps are
you talking about
he can uh even more aggressively than he
has done already Target not just uh
Ukrainian civilian targets but Ukrainian
uh infrastructure uh has already been
playing around with the risks to nuclear
power plants but there's much more he
can do to [ __ ] the Ukrainian economy
if he puts his mind to it and he can
also uh God forbid but try and Target uh
Ukrainian decision makers you know
president zielinski himself and Targets
in Kiev that have been left untouched
for quite a number of months now so uh
there's uh really I repeat a long way to
go uh Putin will be hoping uh uh
desperately I think increasingly
desperately that by squeezing Europe on
energy this winter and threatening
dire retribution if anyone he touches
Russian territory he will start sowing
doubts and split Western cohesion
breaking Europe and the United States
away from Ukraine that's his goal and I
think he still believes he can achieve
it even though he's clearly in a
considerable domestic political crisis
on Friday last he was saying that he had
no change of plans and now he's done
something that we know from Western
intelligence sources he really really
did not want to do which is at least
partial mobilization which makes the war
so much more real for uh people in the
big Russian cities like Moscow and Saint
Petersburg I'm interested in what could
happen within Russia we'll talk about
the number of people you know arrested
in Russia you're speaking there about
how the Walker become more unpopular
because of this mobilization and what do
you think the interaction in Russia
could be and is there a chance I guess
that it could be some kind of Uprising
in Russia that tries to stop the war or
even you know overthrows Putin I guess
well this is an increasingly fluid
crisis for all concerned and so I
suppose it's rational out any scenario
but uh President Putin uh has a good KGB
officer has a very very very good grip
uh on security uh in Russia and I don't
think Uprising is particularly likely
but we have just seen him cave in on a
critical policy matter to Russian Hawks
who are even further to the right of him
so he is politically vulnerable even if
he's not facing a a palace coup uh or uh
popular demonstrations that get out of
control uh and uh I I feel that in some
ways his announcement today it marks the
beginning of a of a long slow uh end to
the Putin era
that's interesting to to hear um your
assessment of how he is politically and
the strength that he has uh politically
uh in Moscow
um what as far as you're aware is a
situation on the ground we've obviously
had these uh weeks where we've been told
about these very strong Ukrainian
advancements then other reports that
perhaps there's more resistance from
Russia than they were finding initially
what's your assessment of where the war
is at
my uh I'm not I I don't have any uh
great Insight knowledge but my
impression is that uh the uh the scale
of the Russian uh uh withdrawal has been
more damaging politically than
militarily uh some Russian forces have
withdrawn in good order uh they're
perhaps now on better defended lines
than they were before and it's quite
likely that in the Northeast the
ukrainians are going to find it
difficult to make significant further
advances between now and when winter
descends and it gets a bit more
difficult and Ukrainian capacity really
runs out so uh I I think the ukrainians
have done uh what they needed to do
before the winter which is to persuade
their Western backers that they can win
they can make progress uh provided they
are supported economic comically and
militarily by the west but we may not
see much more in the way of a big change
on the ground for some months to come
now